I love that shot when he licks that what
a guy that's what I wanted Carlton
Dragan had been him to do when they're
fighting it so I'm gonna lick each other
that yeah tongue Basset song bats clean
each other off like cats yeah that's all
good
we ought to do it at the end of like a
big battle or something they're all just
in a pile happy Tuesday reject nation
it's Greg Alva here jonald we're gonna
watch the trailer the next one for a
venom no boy what would we do that
it's my favorites new venom quote not we
are venom the end of the month so I want
to thank everyone who's joined our
patreon for this month of July and quite
a few pledges so thank you to everyone
over there as it heads up we do weekly
Q&A s music video coverage a lot of
reward tears actually main thing is we
do full-length TV show reactions
I personally cover attack on Titan
covered most of season four the flash
started up Gotham John covers Riverdale
Atlanta Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
just started up channel zero together we
cover my hero academia Cobra Kai Jessica
Jones and black and lightning like I
said a whole bunch of stuff over there
so thank you guys so much we had a good
month in July let's move on to this
venom trailer
the holy seem to find myself questioning
something the government may not be
working on something taken
look around the world who do you see
the planet brink of collapse nuclear
holocaust man and symbiote combined
you race your species the higher
life-form
whoa damn we cannot just hurt people
[Music]
[Music]
it's not completely awful you have no
idea what you're scaring me right now
well and you just might survive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
the interesting truth exactly the best
trailer for this movie so far each one
gets better venomous trailer animals is
so much venom yeah
when there are shots in this that were
in the earlier trailers that didn't have
venom elements that have them now like
when he's freaking out inside yeah I
think the venom design looks great all
the different ways is the symbiotic like
when he has the axes and everything oh
yeah it was great and I love how like
sinister twisted venom does seem they
keep doing these tag lines of like he's
not a hero and this is the first trailer
that we've gotten where I'm like yeah he
doesn't seem like a sinister guy yeah
well you get the sense for the odds that
venom and Eddie Brock are gonna be at ya
know cuz there's that whole
back-and-forth that keeps kind of
persisting about like we're not gonna
hurt innocent people and venom keeps
being like we can do whatever we want so
I'm curious as to how they're gonna
approach the antihero ain't gonna yeah
and it seems to be borrowing elements a
lot from the lethal protector series
that we did some research on they're
experimenting on all the prisoners a
test subject so it seems like there's
gonna be multiple people with the
symbiotes yeah this kind of herbs yeah
you see yeah you see a woman there who
has it and then you see Carlton Drake at
the end and I believe he's playing riot
from what it looks like here which looks
awesome that was one killer ass shot
like there were shots in here that looks
straight out of a venom comic book which
I really did appreciate a lot the
contrast between Eddie Brock and venom
is looking better than it ever has I'm
beginning to get a better sense for what
this tone of the movie might actually be
it seems they're gonna have a dark sense
of humor throughout and I like that
venom seems to have like a full-on
personality's more than just saying cool
lines with a cool voice yeah you get the
sense for Venom's actual like not to
borrow a different characters name but
think you know like the carnage that
will ensue around this character the
sort of juggernaut that it could be and
I also like this trailer emphasizes just
the size you know like you see Tom Hardy
even in mid
you realize how much size and weight he
picks up through that and they have shot
at the end where they're fighting
they're looking like Hugh yeah that
looks really cool and this also makes me
curious too about just how much symbiote
madness we're gonna see because you know
we it's confirmed like they're testing
this on a few different of their
patients as well as Carlton Drake at the
end like we learned in the lethal
protector comic they're supposed to be
multiples of them yeah so let's be
spider-man but you know I'm wondering if
that shot at the end is the part at
Comic Con that everyone saw were venom
bit off someone's head yeah that's
exactly I was like this is an advertised
as a red band but I would really like to
see that image though where he bites
someone's head off the phrase from
comic-con was lots of head chomping well
that too he keeps commenting on like all
your different limbs and organs for us
to feast of it you kind of get a hint at
what Eddie Brock's Ark into this will be
it seems as if Eddie is having a thing
where he's rejecting it at first or you
know they'll have that fun in-game
sexual what's going on with my body yeah
as it keeps going - he does have some
line in here where he does say something
along the lines of like the power is not
so bad I forget exactly yeah yeah yeah
it's all I can just rewind this back and
find it that power so I imagine that by
the end the whole we are venom line that
even says yeah I feel like it another
note one thing the other trailers didn't
really give me was the fun vibe yes he
has to have that element of this looks
like a lot of fun yeah it looks like an
edgy kind of it really does look like an
antihero story and that's a cool paper
dad everything they've been advertising
and the tag lines and what we've all
heard from the director and Tom Hardy
this actually seems to be that I'm
there's a far less questionable than
I've ever been about the movie if you
guys want to see a somewhat Eddie Brock
performance check out the movie lock
it's what I kept thinking of when I was
watching that movie you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation please
click that notification Bell could
subscribe bird and suck and you can
check us on patreon we've got full line
TV show reactions
- neighs and music video coverage love
to have you become a patron eject today